president Trump and Joe Biden gearing up
for their big debate on Tuesday basement
Biden is off the campaign Trail today to
prepare while his campaign says it
expects president Trump to quote lie
through his teeth the former VP talking
trash and says he's ready to
go I'm not the guy who can't run up or
down the plat the the ramp to get to the
the uh to deliver a commencement speech
in an academy I'm not the guy who says
inject bleach in your arm and I'm I'm
used to dealing with bullies the point
is that
uh rather than say how I'm going to do
again watch me I've not been a bad
debater and we'll see what I'm going to
do is insist that we talk about what the
pre the president's failures and
president Trump weighing in on what to
expect and it sounds like it could get
nasty oh I think I'm the one with that
experience I've just been doing this for
a few years he's been doing it for 47
years plus and you know I mean he has a
a tremendous disadvantage really if you
think about it but I have a much better
record than he does I look at uh Hunter
Biden today where he stole millions of
dollars stole Millions his father should
leave the campaign because his father
was in on it his father knew
everything all right Dana brought this
point up yesterday Juan let's just say
in the beginning of the debate the
president turns to Joe Biden and says
Joe had a Russian billionaire pay your
son $35 million what was that for what
do you think Joe should say you say Mr
President let's have a debate on the
issues and not on slander baseless
slander it's not true and it's baseless
slander where the money went no because
in fact Ron Johnson a US senator using
Russian propaganda and all the
investigative powers of the Senate
basically clear Joe Biden of any
wrongdoing any influence on American
policy they have the receipts look I'm
going to tell you something to me what
comes across in that exchange that we
just played Jesse is how hilarious the
last few months months on this show have
been because I have heard you guys say
Joe Biden's lost his marbles Joe Biden
can't do it Joe Biden is really weak and
now you're saying you know Joe Biden's a
great orator he we expect him to do well
in this are you saying the five lower
expectations too much for well that's
what I'm thinking that's what I'm
thinking you got it because you know let
me finish this because you know now you
see President Trump he's saying you know
Biden was on drugs remember that yes
then he was saying performance enhancing
drugs not like mushrooms
whatever I don't know I got to check
with you guys performance enhancing me
and now he said today I got a big kick
out of this he said Biden's wearing that
mask you know why plastic surgery
oh wow how did that get by me I didn't
even hear that today but by the way when
Juan retells Trump's stuff he doesn't
retell it as it's supposed to be which
is a joke the Trump's plastic surgery
line was priceless and hilarious but
you're like you wouldn't believe what
this man said man covering for 4 years
and every day it's a surprise like oh I
can't believe he said that my word
where's my fainting couch yeah well I
mean he says outrageous stuff regularly
but you you say it's a meme it's a joke
but you know I'm not sure everybody am I
supposed to be on the joke when he says
Chris Wallace is under the control of
the radical left I think some of the
jokes with due respect may go over your
head all right right well I don't know I
I huh I'm kind of interested in the fact
that it's only 90 minutes
because you know Trump wanted it longer
but if it was the if it was the Biden
campaign it would have been 20 minutes
long with four five minute breaks
included but I don't know I thought that
would have landed better I I thought it
was really good I was laughing on the
inside I I need a fainting couch um you
called on me yes I've called on you D so
the other thing Biden said is that he's
like yeah I've not really been preparing
for these debates and I'm like well then
what are you doing all day I actually
believe that both of these men are
competitors that want to win yes you
know I heard he was getting a fitting
today for an
earpiece okay can I just I do have one
other point
thoughe I shouldn't I shouldn't try to
make a joke um but the thing is debate
moments that you were talking about
yesterday like the one the real
memorable ones those are made those
don't just happen you have to be
prepared you have to know your opponent
well enough to be like you know what
their weak spot is for example Hunter
Biden that would definitely be a spot
where you could get Joe Biden to react
yes he'll be picking that scab all right
so a few weeks ago on the show I said
that both candidates during the debate
need to download the Pizza Hut app and
whoever downloads it orders a pizza and
has it delivered first gets to be
president but I've amended that so now I
think they should each download Tik Tok
learn a dance and perform it perform it
on stage and whoever can do that again
gets to be president I think Chris
Wallace this is for you this is a gimme
you don't have to give me credit for
this give them a cognitive function test
give both candidates either that or
questions from a garden variety psych
test and let's see how they do that'll
be television man woman that that was a
joke too yes oh he's a very stable
genius yeah I thought that was pretty
ridiculous and revealing yeah all right
we're